[Music]
okay they'll be from Atlanta Georgia and
I was wondering you can you believe in
free will
feels like the idea of choice is the
biggest argument for free will but this
choice real or the just an idea in our
heads if I look at my life I feel like
I'm here through a series of single
decisions and it just kind of feels very
linear and kind of on a track but let's
say sure what do you think about it
Thanks so is there such a thing as free
will the answer is clearly it depends
what you mean so I am so compelled by
these tests where they they have brain
scans going on working real-time and
then the subject is asked to make a
choice and they can see on the brain
skin that the choice has already been
made before the person is able to
articulate it or even watch the choice
have been made have it but a little
bounce back and forth and then settle on
another choice it's a this is a
wonderful question but that there is no
free will that to me is an extraordinary
claim because I feel that I have made
choices and this might be what you're
driving that I feel that I have made
choices freely based on things that have
happened around me based on the
environment and my experiences and my
perception of the experiences of others
so in other words if there really were
absolutely no free will could you then
predict what every single person in the
universe or on earth is going to do and
where he or she will end up and then
furthermore can that not be influenced
by some cosmic force that were forces
that we can't assess could be it just
doesn't seem reasonable I think much
more reasonable is our brains are
complicated and they got this big or as
big as they are organically through
evolution with layer being added upon
layer so our ability to choose is often
confuse
our ability to make choices and is often
affected by the environment by our
experiences and by biochemistry the
shape of our brain so I think the answer
is clearly some of each
[Music]